I like to take you back for a moment in
time to 1975 1975 I was 15 years old and
I was playing in the US Open in Lincoln
Nebraska all the way from Seattle
Washington and there were chess
grandmasters whoo in Seattle we didn't
have a lot of chess grandmasters so it's
like really exciting to be around these
players and to watch their games in 1975
was a kind of a very special period in
time we were still in the afterglow if
you will of the Bobby Fischer Boris
Spassky match Bobby Fischer you know it
was scheduled in that year to defend his
title
it was the after after the Nixon affair
the Watergate affair
there was a time it was a time of Bruce
Lee and the martial arts were exploding
on the field it was also an interesting
time for computers
computers were becoming more in the
human consciousness
they weren't just for geeks and national
security but computers there were going
to be come household items and in 1975
when I was playing it the US Open
several conversations really were the
topic the first one was would computers
ever ever be able to compete against the
world's best players and if the answer
was no then why and if the answer was
yes then in what other field couldn't
the computer compete if they could
compete with us in chess
could they compete couldn't they compete
with us in poetry or in story making or
any topic and so these were heavily
debated issues would the computer ever
beat a world champion the second topic
of conversation that involved that was
linked to the computer was if the
computers became the world champions or
the best in the world
what openings would they choose and why
would they choose those openings and
would openings be solved in the sense
that there was always going to be an
only and best move if you will so these
were very very heated discussions and
the reason why the opening discussion in
particular became so very heated was
this idea that in chess you have a wide
variety of openings and you see these
grandmasters you see some openings for
example at one time we'll have to go
back maybe 10 years or less it was
everybody it just seemed like the the
strongest positional players the
strongest dynamic players it just seemed
to me like everybody was playing this
fashion akov Sicilian it was like man it
just exploded and and it became super
popular and today is like maybe 1/10
150th of the games are a sveshnikov
sicilian there was a time during the
karpov area era when everybody and I
mean everybody and his brother would
play not nights III allowing the
nimzo-indian but rather night f3 and
black was playing Queens Indian like
Anatoly Karpov was leading the charge
and the Queen's Indian became a
yeah yeah yeah the Queen's Indian
everybody was playing the black side of
the Queen's Indian and so forth and so
on
it's sort of like openings and defenses
fall into fashion and greatly so and
they fall out of fashion and once again
greatly so 1975 I was watching the games
of a grandmaster by the name of Arthur
Fiske wire an Arthur busy wire yes I am
yes he played in many many many US
Championships many many US Opens and
there was Arthur busy wire on his board
the Grandmaster Earth abyss glare and
virtually every round he was playing the
Berlin defense the Berlin defense right
so here we are having all these heated
discussions about openings and defenses
and then we were thinking wow at the
turn of the millennia in the year 2000
what would be the most popular openings
and defenses what here we are 25 years
from now what would we predict would be
the most popular maybe it was decided
that he for was unplayable or d4 was
unplayable maybe them maybe the openings
of tomorrow would be the orangutan or
maybe something like the Grob attack you
know playing on the flanks you know
accelerated Grob attack type of things
none of us I mean none of us thought
that the Berlin defense would become the
most popular defense of the 21st century
I think it's there would be Arthur visit
wire a man ahead of his time right
because he had been playing the Berlin
defense like somebody top Arthur we
would joke that somebody taught Arthur
the Berlin defense when he was five it
was all he learned because that was his
opening and I asked Arthur I quizzed him
deeply about
the Berlin defense and why he liked it
and he explained to me and I think you
did a very good job in hindsight that
the Berlin defense was one of those
defenses from black that allowed for
three results okay so what he was
basically trying to say and I understood
what he meant to say was that when
you're black and you play for certain
for example something like a classical
Rui Lopez and you play for example a
Braer defense that normally speaking
white has an advantage of sorts whether
slighter or what-have-you
that's long lasting if you play a
marshall gambit more than likely the
games going to be draw and if white
wants a draw against the Marshall gambit
he can definitely choose a variation
that's drawn conversely in Arthur's view
the Berlin defense created an imbalance
which it does which allowed for all
three results and today it's like every
Grandmaster in the world has the Berlin
defense in his repertoire magnus carlsen
world champion Viswanath on and on
five-time world champion
Chikara nakamura wesley so the two
highest rated players in the United
States just go down a list a very very
dynamic player for example Veselin
Topalov who plays Sicilians Sicilian
night off is a favorite of veselin he
plays the Berlin defence okay
so the topic of the conversation tonight
topic of the lecture tonight was this
idea of first of all let's try to
understand the Berlin and what it is
that all of these top grandmasters are
finding attractive and then the other
interesting thing about the Berlin
defense is what I was explaining how
openings and defenses go through these
periods of fashion where they become
ultra ultra pop popular and then
disappear the berlin defense really
burst into our consciousness during the
2000 World Chess Championship match
between Garry Kasparov and Vladimir
Kramnik and Garry Kasparov as we all
know was doing terrible things as the
world champion he was just like beating
everybody and beating them very very
badly it was considered that Vladimir
Kramnik was not Gary's match but then on
the other hand who was he had to play
somebody and so Vladimir Kramnik I got
his opportunity and Vladimir had a real
real problem what was he going to do
against Gary's efore so the Berlin
defense Knight f6 come has a very very
long history because if you think about
it from this position what could be more
natural than oops sorry Knight f6
developing piece okay if white is
prompted to play a move like d2 d3
responding to the threat of Knight takes
e4 well then this whole setting up the
central pawn duo with c3 d4 has been
delayed by a tempo and it's considered
that blacks should be happy that he's
cost white a tempo in his plan okay so
by far the most challenging move is
castles and Vladimir Kramnik
asked the simple question what am i what
are you going to do if I take your pawn
Knight takes e4 ok so again there are
several moves at rook e1 Knight d6 going
back attacking the bishop on b5 Knight
takes
five Knight takes e5 rook takes e5 check
Bishop e7 has been played numerous times
about highest most elite level that if
you look at the pawn structure you go
jeez this is so most symmetrical pawn
structure in the world and it's going to
be very very hard for the first player
to prove an advantage which practice has
shown to be the case not to say that
white doesn't win some of those games
but really black has an easy easy time
so by far the most challenging is the
move d2 d4 and basically this has been
known for decades and it was known by
the Latimer kramnik as he was preparing
for Garry Kasparov and Garret and
Vladimir needed a particular type of
opening defense that he wanted against
Gary he wanted Queens off the board
because Gary was such a dynamic
attacking player if he if he could just
start by trading Queens at the very
start of the game he takes away a lot of
Gary's firepower so this one fit the
bill not only did he take away trade it
at after the forcing moves takes takes
takes white wins back his pawn not only
has Vladimir traded off the Queen's
literally right away but he's also taken
off a bishop White has lost the
LightSquared Bishop for a knight to
deficits in the position for black first
Black has lost the right to castle maybe
not the worst thing ever
secondly black does have these double
pawns okay those are the two deficits
that black has conversely White's extra
pawn on the Queen on the King side this
majority is
really hard for white to exploit and and
I'm on a really good day white is going
to try to play for f4 and g4 and f5 and
put his majority to work from blacks
point of view he needs to solve his
development where is he going to put
this Bishop Bishop here Bishop here
needs to solve the question of this King
normally speaking in the old days that
got sorted right away white often played
the move rook d1 check King e8 and away
you go
in other words in the days of Arthur
busy wire when the players reach this
position this move rook d1 check King e8
or automatics play continued from this
point practice however has shown in a
very strange way I would pose a question
to white after you've played the remove
rook d1 could you please explain to me
the role of your rook on a1 where is
that guy going when are you going to
bring that rook on a1 into the game
maybe only after you develop your knight
and your bishop you'll figure out maybe
you to move the rook back to e1 to open
up the rook coming to d1 so over the
course of time the move rook d1 was
delayed and white began to think well
maybe I should bring my Knight to c3
which makes part of the very very
logical sense then maybe I'll bring my
bishop I don't know maybe two for maybe
two g5 I'll put this rook on d1 and this
rook on e one for check so Knight c3
became all the rage
and it's strange how chess develops the
thinking of chess develops over time so
for example black Desai said okay well
I'm going to solve the question the
issue of my king I'll just move my
bishop out I'll move my bishop to say I
don't know
d7 okay so what would you do
let's say you would give me a check very
very logical check to my king I will
move my king to the Kings side hmm Queen
side I beg your pardon
you would move your rook for example to
d1 and I would say hmm I don't know I
don't know but okay I'll just make look
for my king
b7 b6 and now white would start thinking
okay white would start to think what
should I do next
what should I do I've done everything oh
I know I I could I could bring this guy
into the game I could play rook to e1
and leave it up to black to decide what
he wants to do black says well I know
what I want to do I'll play Bishop b4
and I'll get into bishops of opposite
colors so that my next turn I'll take
this night you'll recapture my bishop my
bishop will go to e6 and I'll be
perfectly safe okay so white starts
thinking thinking saying gosh I can see
what you black want to do oh I know I'll
play G to g4 I'll Drive your knight back
maybe after g4 you won't be so anxious
to go to h6 or you won't be if you go to
e7 then you've got to solve something I
know I'll play g4 you'll go back to e7
not to h6 I'll take you'll take and I'll
play h3 and I've got this a really great
idea
yes sir yes exactly we could we could
play G to G for in this moment as well
okay and we'll come back to this in just
a second
whoops be pleased oh okay just a second
we'll get here and we're going to play
h2 h3 okay we're going to go h2 h3 so
white has this great dream what white
wants to do is go night to d4 F to F for
use his bring his knight into the center
and push his pawns and suddenly there's
this very annoying move hmm you don't
want to really take on h5 and you don't
want black trading and taking on g4 what
are you going to do Julia maybe e6 right
now v e6 and let's say well black has to
capture that fella
yeah Knight d4 and you might say that at
the end of this whole series of trades
trades trades I don't know something
like well maybe you will just take this
guy instead black plays I don't know say
bishop here you're going to take take
take and you know before you know it
blacks ending up getting counter play
he's going to play rook to h3 he's going
to double his rooks maybe he can harass
this Jeep on sometimes with rook h4 and
boom the game gets really really really
really simplified let's go back for a
moment to this moment before rook F e1
and we'll just take a quick look at g4
G for the night drops back as we've
previously seen Knight to e7
you got issue how are you going to
defend this pawn on g4 well the very
obvious move is h2 h3 black once again
does the very same thing
h7 h5 darn it
no now this early g4 has created an
opportunity that didn't exist for black
to make counter play against g4 okay so
oops how did how should white deal with
this one should he play rugby for isn't
that encouraging perhaps c5 should he
play Knight h2 well Knight h2 doesn't
impress on many counts after for example
takes takes rook takes h2 isn't
necessarily immediately worrisome but
let's say black plate a move like Knight
d5 he blunders upon there's something a
little bit scary here for white that
might white might feel a little bit
uncomfortable about that this rook like
one day and on a very bad day and at
that land on the square H 1 so after for
example a position like this there might
be issues with f6 takes Bishop d6 and
takes and suddenly it's black who has
the initiative so we go back to how
chess theory evolved and the remarkable
thing was white the most popular move
here for white
became h2 h3 so what white started to do
is realize for him that if he's ever
going to get his kingside going just to
put a position on the board for a moment
Bishop to d7 g4 Knight back to e7 King G
to h5 King g3 he's going to be able he's
going to want to be able to protect the
pawn on g4 often times with his king
okay but when you get to such positions
you have to be very careful that that
you simply haven't helped black develop
his rook that hasn't moved okay so the
Berlin defense today right now has
become one of the most popular defenses
to e4 from everybody from everybody at
the top plays the Berlin and the Berlin
defense not only decided the outcome of
the 2000 World Chess Championship match
but also the 2014 World Chess
Championship match as it was the final
game game 11 Magnus Carlsen white vision
on black a lecture I had made earlier in
the week about that decided the outcome
of the match okay
when you're black at the highest levels
and even at the amateur levels the
choice of defense is really really tough
one sometimes you want to play a sharp
I don't know Sicilian sometimes you want
to play a solid I don't know caro-kann
or French defense suddenly with the
Berlin you're getting everything at once
you're getting an imbalance position
that gives you chances to win as black
as well as a solid position that's
really really hard for the first player
to break down so here I am the Year 2015
saying
you guys should learn to play like
Arthur Misbah from 1975 he wrote the
book on the Berlin defense and he is
putty he inadvertently pioneered the way
so lectures I think should be
interactive and I'm going to invite
yourselves to play against me and we'll
logically go through the whys of the
moves that you chosen and why I feel
that blacks should go with the flow okay
so leaving it out to yourselves
you could play you can bring your night
out you could start your advance over
here you could I don't know maybe do
something else and this is the position
that the grandmasters the top
grandmasters can't make heads or tails
of they can't make up their minds
whether it's h3 Knight c3 b3 rook d1
check um it's very frustrating for them
and then you leave their chess engines
on to I mean they put this position in
their chess engines and let it think a
week and they come back and the things
going zero zero three zero five still
undecided so let's take a crack who
would like to play white move here
Knight g5 okay haha you don't get to
okay so Knight g5 okay this is a very
logical looking move because on the one
hand if after all of this conversation
that I've been having about how
important it is imperative or
what-have-you to be able to move your
pawn forwards then you got to get your
night out of the way and what could be
sweeter then moving your knight with a
gain of tempo because you're threatening
my pawn on f7 I don't want to play this
move I don't want to play this move
because after this move first of all you
can
recapture and I don't even have the
benefit of the two bishops okay so
long-term I think white is just going to
torture black for a long time even
though again a lot of games have been
drawn from these types of setups I will
instead defend mainly I'm going to
defend my f7 pawn by moving my king at
the moment you might think to yourself
well that was a good trade of moves but
in truth my king on d8 is actually
misplaced I want to bring a rook to the
open file so I know my king on d8 is
going to move whether voluntarily or not
your turn what would be your follow up
to Knight to g5 rook David one okay so
now after rook David one I'm thinking
that that was actually a good move by
yourselves I was actually hoping that
you wouldn't notice but my your knight
on f3 defended the d4 square I was
hoping you would play some passive move
for example like Knight c3 so I was
hoping that I'd be able to get to bring
my knight let me just put this move on
the board I'll play a bad move for white
forgive me play a bad move for white I
put my knight on this wonderful square d
4 I'd be attacking this pawn on c2 I'd
give myself opportunities for Knight e
to check and if you did something well
that's already bad but hmm well let's
just say this is wonderful black as
suddenly you know attacking with a lone
Knight writes in trouble
so rook d1 stopped me very cleverly from
rerouting my knight to a nice square but
after you've played rook
Knight f3 to g5 I'm going to play the
move
h7 h6 I'm going to simply kick your
knight back your Knight has two choices
it can go to e4 f3 I'm going to just
pick one I'm going to pick e4 as the
more favorable choice let us say because
otherwise why did you play Knight f3 to
g5 right you just gave me the extra move
h7 h6 I'll pull my Bishop out Bishop to
e6 so I've got a good square now for my
Bishop I'm assuming for example that you
might want to develop your knight and
I'll develop my Bishop so you've got
your Knight to e4 you've got your Knight
to c3 they're kind of on each other's
whose so to speak at the moment so
they're duplicating a one another I'm
hoping that you will play a poor move
I'm hoping for this move g4 you usually
if it's not well prepared it's simply a
bad move now you'll scuse me you're
chasing my knight to a very attractive
square and you're putting your pawn on
pries so I'm already trust me on this
one
I'm already more than satisfied with the
outcome of the position for black even
though you haven't made any moves
I prefer blacks position as like you
played natural good looking moves and
already just like that you've got a
disadvantage okay we'll try again
another choice oops not another one
Julian Knight to c3 okay so here I've
got you gave me an option that I if you
hit play group d1 check I'm moving my
king
you played Knight c3 so you've given me
an option of either forcing my king to
e8 or on it and right now giving me the
option of going Queen side I'm going to
try to exploit you okay I'm going to go
Queen Queen side with the move Bishop to
d7 my intention is to play king c8 again
Jelena b2 b3 yeah okay b2 b3 I think
this is like one of the hardships for
the white player in the Berlin it's not
always clear what the best square darn
it
is for the vision I mean f4 is a nice
square no question about it
f4 is a nice square but then in a
certain sense doesn't the bishop stand
in front of the pawn g5 is a nice square
well first of all it's a check but then
won't that encourage black to play h6
you put your Bishop on d2 it's kind of
passive when you fianchetto the bishop
you're looking for an exciting
opportunity to get to play e5 e6 okay
I'm going to step aside King c8 let me
just follow up for a moment for white
Bishop b2 and let me see now I have to
go into a thing and decide what I want
to do it's not always so clear to me
what it is I want to do with black in
such situations let me play let me play
a natural move for a moment
I'm going to try this move h 7 h 6 okay
so what my idea of h 6 is is I want to
stop Knight g5 I want to give my bishop
a useful square on e6 okay your turn
rook D 1 rook e1 Knight e4 whatever you
want to go what do you want to do rook a
d1 very natural move I'm going to play B
7 B 6 ok so finally I'm not quite there
yet but I have idea to play c5 and
Bishop c6 in King b7 i want to put my
bishop on this diagonal alright your
turn
help them out people help them out it's
you it's me versus the world I got the
whole world lined up against me h2 h3
okay I like this move it's very common
to preparing the move g4 okay now let's
say that I'm no longer satisfied with my
knight on f5 I'm going to reroute my
knight
I'm going to play 97 with a very
specific idea that on either g6 where it
could come to f4 or if you prematurely
move your Knight to e4 I want to take up
residence on d5 yes Julian 9 David 4
Wow okay ah I'm gonna humming a knight
David 4 I usually don't see that in
these types this moment okay I'll attack
the knight
oh you're sacrificing yay well now
you've gone back hmm okay yeah but I
normally speaking I gloriously get to
stick my bishop just a second let me
just put it I get to stick my glorious
bishop here not usually when I'm upon up
Knight g6 rook Edgar won yay okay so I
want to prepare Bishop to d6 I will play
rook to g8 why do I play rook to g8
I just want to refortified on g7 I could
have played Bishop e7 hold it sorry let
me say I could have played Bishop e7 a
moment ago
but I'm hoping that when you play 95
I'll trade now get a tempo I want to
have my cake and eat it too
in other words okay so very interesting
what white has done is he sacrificed a
pond to try to refute my position and
what white is about to discover is
actually I've got a pretty solid
position isn't really going to be hard
hard to refute okay we're going to go
back no worries
it's a try it's a try it's just a try
what we're doing right now together you
and I is exactly what chess grandmasters
do all over the world whether they're
preparing for the World Chess
Championship or the state championship
or the Bundesliga they sit down with one
another and play devil's advocate
against the other usually they have
their chess engines working overtime as
well right beside them as well but this
is what they do and they come to
conclusions and if they discover a new
idea that hadn't previously been played
well then they're super excited okay
we'll take another and we're going to
we've just got a few minutes before the
blitz tournament begins Matthew what
line have you played this line as white
yourself and in this position what's
your favorite turn at you come around to
the move h2 h3 as well
okay very exciting very exciting indeed
let me take a different approach against
h2 h3 than I previously just to mix it
mix it up for a moment let me play
Knight d7 normally speaking the reason I
voluntarily retreat because I feel like
I've gained something yes I've gained
something I provoked you to play h2 h3
and I never really liked the square
piece of it
my dream Square actually is the e6
square so I have ideas on a very good
day of playing Knight g6
9f 896 there I think I'll be block
hating your majority so the fact that
I've managed to gain h2 h3 you know
makes me super confident I give myself a
pat on the back you know but h2 h3 is
main move and now Knight c3 okay for me
it's kind of easy in the sense I know
I'm going to have to move a move my king
so I'll play the move King e8 rather
than worry about should I play h6 should
I play h5 should I play b6 should I play
a 5 a 4 all of those other moves I can
choose later it's a real jungle out
there and I have to decide what I'm
going to do
but King e8 is one of those moves that's
always useful so I'm going to play King
e8 rook Edgar one okay so you're giving
me an opportunity that I normally don't
get hmm okay
well I'll try to take advantage of you
I'll exploit your move order if I can't
go Knight d5 okay so I'm hoping that
you'll trade and help UND's and I'm a
happy camper
okay so Knight to d5 your trip Knight e4
you're not a nice person nobody told you
a nice person I had this great plan
and you double-crossed me okay but 94
aren't you provoking yes you are
Knight to be four so in the immortal
words of my trainer Nick alignment of
gift me your palm gift me your paw
rook e2 okay so now rookie - okay
I believe in development the bishop is
coming out to f5 so I have a cruel
intention of night c2 and in case of
rook c2 Bishop a4 or simply Bishop e4
Knight C 2 in the other case I want to
gift me your fun night David for oh boy
now things are really getting
complicated
oh my goodness oh boy
okay so let's let's boldly analyze the
obvious for a moment Bishop takes rook
takes I believe in development rook to
d8 so my cruel intention is rook d4 in
night c2
not gonna see threes an excellent move
see three defends the night attacks my
night bad people
I'll drop in on you I'll go 93
so on a good yeah Bishop g5 that's a
nice tempo I like Bishop g5 I'm going to
play rook d5 no no no the e6 is also on
the agenda we'll go back in a second
that's a very reasonable looking move as
well so at this moment things have
heated up I'm not I don't know what is
what's what at the moment but I have
ideas of Knight xb2
I have ideas good or bad if rook takes
e5 and finally sometimes it's very
useful for black to get in a tempo move
h6 that helps me contain compress
withhold your King side majority okay
your turn rook d1 holy cow isn't my
birthday
rook d1 okay I don't know but I love
grabbing pawn oh yes so Oh
alert alert check this out my knight is
hanging okay so now I start analyzing I
start thinking okay if I go Bishop a3
maybe you'll play Bishop c1 maybe you'll
play Knight c2 I'll give a check tanks
tanks Knight takes Knight takes I got
two pawns but wait a minute I don't like
that I'm going to have to retreat my
knight 94
take upon take upon oops that's about
the worst Mouse lip you can make in a
tournament game don't don't do this at
home folks over right let's say early
there we go
so you take upon I take upon you give me
check I go here you give me hockey MOT
okay that's good to know
so I've got to do something very clever
to avoid getting mated and it doesn't
look like I've got anything super clever
on my I was hoping that c5 would but
note the knight on c6 still still holds
on so in this position we we go back to
this position that line of checkmate
I should I need to play h6
I've got to validate the ii it is a
sacrifice of the pawn a good or not so
rugby to rook takes B to H takes g5 rook
takes b7 let's say King comes out to d7
and we got another very very typical
ending one of the things that black
oftentimes aspires to is with a pawn on
e5 if I can get on a very good day a
position where my King would be nicely
on e6 I would have an opportunity of
gaining an edge at this moment I don't
say I don't know who's better maybe
maybe after rook b8 I'm in this very
annoying pen maybe that's very good for
you maybe rook takes a seven if you've
won upon at the moment maybe you're
satisfied with that Julian just a second
let me check my rulebook yes what's G
for I can't I take that with either
and checkmate me brilliantly on the
first but at the moment I'm two pawns up
right and in case of check I have the
outstanding retreat ah and even that's
not a hundred percent clear but again
this is exactly again how grandmasters
choose their openings and I think that
just this little demonstration that
we've had with ourselves goes to show
it's not easy it's not easy finding the
right way whether you're white because
the the flexibility of the positions so
again I just want to encourage you
you've got a classical defense all three
results are possible it's really really
cool defense the Berlin is the 21st
century ah opening